this is a really unusual thing more than
anything
the other day eric trump one of donald
trump's
kids went on fox news and
he said he was part of the lgbtq
community
something which certainly has not been
made public if indeed it's what he was
trying to say
and initially the speculation was either
eric misspoke
there was some weird grammatical
ambiguity
or he's saying he's bisexual i guess
let's take a look at the video
clip the content is from fox and friends
in a segment
about supposed lgbtq
trump supporters take a look at in the
new york times
and it talks it's this her her name is
chris she doesn't want to give her last
name
because she says that her colleagues at
work it wouldn't go well with them
she lives in manhattan she's in her 50s
secret trump voter that's right she is
she's gay she said her 401k went up with
your dad
19.6 percent gas prices uh better than
they were under obama she goes on to say
that obamacare
was 560 a month for her and she had lost
her job
so she was priced out she talks about
crime in the neighborhood
she talks about bill de blasio and how
he's uh inept
uh that the russia trump russia thing
the clintons fingerprints are all over
it
um she calls joe biden weak is this but
she doesn't want to use her last name
and there are a lot of people that might
be voting for your dad that aren't
admitting it
and it was brett stevens who's been a
critic of of your uh dad who wrote the
editorial
so are you counting on this person on
the secret voter
ainslie that person's there i'm telling
you i see it every day the lgbt
community
they are incredible and you should see
how they've come out in full force for
my father every single day i'm part of
that community and we love the man and
thank you for protecting our
neighborhoods and thank you for
protecting our cities yeah so so eric
trump says he's part of that community
now
either he's saying he's bisexual i guess
or it's some kind of grammatical
vagary he meant something else if we put
the actual word for word quote up on the
screen
what he said was the community
they are incredible and you should see
how they've come out in full force for
my father every single day
i'm part of that community and we
love the man so it does seem that eric
trump is saying
he is a member of the lgbt community
that comes out for his dad
i was thinking is there any other way
you could parse the grammar
and i guess you could maybe say it was
an inarticulate way
of eric trump saying that he's part of
the community
that hosts people who come out to
support trump
and that he has been part of hosting
lgbt community member
it would be a very weird grammatical uh
a structure for a native english speaker
but i didn't know what to make of it of
course if eric trump were bisexual i
would have no issue with it whatsoever
but it sort of seemed odd now he put out
a statement eventually clarifying but
before we get to the statement
is it possible that the explanation here
is remember eric trump is not known as
you know the smart one necessarily is it
possible eric trump didn't know what
lgbt
meant like he you know it's uh it's the
iwew
union and it's the teamsters and it's
lgbt
it like is it actually possible that
eric trump didn't know what lgbt meant
and he was just like yeah i'm part of it
i'm part of it any group that supports
trump i'm actually a part of
is he possibly that dumb i don't know
but eric trump has now backtracked eric
trump put out a statement to the new
york post saying
to clarify many of our close friends
are part of the lgbt community which was
the intent of my statement
the left has taken that vote for granted
for a long time
and support from the gay community for
my father is incredible
as to me personally as i think you know
i am happily
married i am a happily married man
to my wife lara so i still think it's
possible
that in the moment he would have you
give him any four letters
you know abcd or ghyq whatever he would
have said he listen
they support trump i'm part of the
community it's all great maybe he really
didn't know what it meant
it's all just very weird and you
couldn't script
a more bizarre re-election campaign if
you tried
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches and they're giving you up to 30
percent off
everything in their store when you go to
davidpakman.com
slash watch if you're looking for an
awesome way to update your look
the perfect way to do it is with an
elegant high quality
wristwatch when there's a company like
vincero
there is no reason to go spending
thousands of dollars on a watch
vincero is an american company that's
made it possible to own
an excellent watch without breaking the
bank all of their watches
are masterfully built with high-end
materials
but they're all in the range of about
150 to 250 bucks
i just got a watch from their icon
automatic collection
the one i got is in gunmetal and slate
blue
i love the look it's sleek classy it's
clear that a lot of careful
craftsmanship went into the design
it is definitely my new favorite watch
you'll get up to 30 off everything in
their store
when you go to davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video